pacific rim you said that uh it it's an
action movie
your role not really like the he-man
action part
no not the handsome strong guy in the
movie uh no abdominal muscles going on
right right uh you know
there's definitely like heroic strong uh
characters in the movie i'm much more
sort of a
a nerdy science guy who thinks he's cool
but he winds up kind of looking a little
bit dorky here and there yeah you you
actually uh i've seen i i've not seen
the film yet but i've seen a bunch of
clips and in one of them you bear a
striking resemblance to rick moranis
yeah and ghostbusters in ghostbusters
yeah
yeah uh actually i think if we can put
your character in the movie next to
there's a real similarity
[Music]
it's pretty depressing man you know i
gotta say like why is it depressing
there were parts in the movie where
they've done an amazing job of the
lighting i'm in this cool leather coat i
got these tattoos i like i look like an
action guy it's really cool and then we
shot that sequence and i took a photo
and i sent it to my wife i'm like oh my
god i look like rick morris
you know i've gone full moranus yeah
you've gone
ninth level moranis
now you said it's a you said it it's a
manly set we had uh charlie hunt him on
the show the other day and and and he
said that the director
uh guillermo del toro
had you had a lot of the guys not you
but a lot of the guys working out like
crazy they had to go to boot camp for a
couple of months yeah they were like
hitting tires with sledgehammers and and
he sent me like chocolate
yeah he was like this this is my
favorite chocolate man you know like and
he would be like
like the guys would be all sweaty and
tired and he'd be like charlie this
charlie you'd be like uh i got a great
place where they fried donuts man and
then you can like drink beer
see you should be happy you play the
scientist guy you know what he's the guy
to play i'm either like extremely smart
or extremely dumb and uh in movies and
if i'm ever somewhere in between i'll
have to go to the gym so hopefully that
doesn't happen you know it's like now we
have a a clip here from uh pacific rim
and uh tell us what's happening in this
clip uh
this is i i haven't seen it so i'm not
quite sure what well you're gonna show
but uh
you're in
you're really of no value to me now very
little guy i already touched you once i
don't want to screw up again but uh i
think this is where i'm being chased
from yeah
you're gonna you're gonna beat the
christ out of me what are you talking
about you're you're a good guy i'm going
to touch you reassuringly right now
very very that's also how i touch my
wife
no uh i'm just i believe this is me
running from the monsters
yeah the monsters are sort of after you
because you've mind melded with
something
thing and they're all pissed off and the
monsters are sort of know where you are
and this is you trying unsuccessfully i
think to hide from them so you knew
better than me i don't even have to come
out here
i'm really excited about my film pacific
rim all right i think you will be too
let's take a look